if only there were one surefire way we
could get you there
we serious guest judge ellie kemper
hands out a golden buzzer as other
contestants say goodbye to America's Got
Talent
you are not going through to the live
show you've done this a long time even I
get surprised if this act looks familiar
it's because they are like balance is a
group that placed third last season on
egt known for their super energetic
dance routines that hues light
programming coding and so much more this
time they've got the same coach but the
group is all kids aged 11 to 13
[Applause]
this week's guest judge actress Ellie
Kemper who's clearly a big fan of light
balance kids sick moves if only there
were one surefire way we could get you
there
[Applause]
I just feel so grateful that now we get
a chance to be here and be a part of I
don't know just making making dreams a
reality for these contestants I love
being a part of making dreams come true
it's nice to be a part of saying yes to
someone's dreams but sadly it wasn't all
happy tears good 12 year old Ansley
burns got pretty emotional after she was
eliminated don't cry
[Music]
this season has seen so many outstanding
talents like singer Cody Lee who scored
Gabrielle Union scold and buzzer I love
singing Cody is a 23 year old singer
who's blind and autistic and clearly has
the gift of music
[Music]
Cody and his mom Tina stopped by ET a
week after his stellar audition they
opened up about their AGT experience so
far exciting was it for you to be on
that stage and sing for the judges it
was so awesome were you nervous at all
no I'm happy nearly what was it like for
you mom and for the family really to see
Cody get that kind of reaction from the
judges also the golden buzzer well first
shock I mean even though you know even
though we know like his talent is just
amazing
still you know you run into a lot of
things during his whole life of the
music you run into a lot of I don't know
if it's called Sigma or whatever it's
called but you run into where a lot of
people when you say yeah he's autistic
and blind and then you know they kind of
have that face like oh okay you know
like singing right but then he would
blow them away so it was really shocking
for us because it was nice to see you
know the judges just fall in love with
him and to really see his talent
[Music]
you
[Music]